i always wanted to be a video editor  when i was 14 but i just was like oh i  can't be that's not going to be a real  job and here's my point if you had me as  your much older brother i was 25 you  were 14 because that's what aj had and i  was me and i was like no no right you  would be a better one because if you  believed it all the way you would have  [ __ ] went all in you loved the bmx  like that would have been a little less  thank god you got here and it's amazing  and you're getting better by the day but  you would have been much further along  and that's why for the 15 year old  that's watching this right now what is  that that she's thinking and he's  thinking that's why i don't want them to  give up because you know what really  hurts regret